PARTY IS NOW DESCENDING TO WHAT
IS A NASTY POLITICAL CIVIL WAR.
THE LIKES OF WHICH WE MAY HAVE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
JOINING US NOW, MARCO RUBIO.
SENATOR, I LOOK -- THERE’S A LOT
OF CUBAN AMERICANS.
I GOT TO KNOW MANY OF THEM.
I WILL TELL YOU, IT’S AMAZING
STORIES.
I HAVE A VERY GOOD FRIEND THAT
PASSED AWAY.
HIS LAND, HIS FAMILY LAND WAS
STOLEN.
HIS NEIGHBOR’S LAND WAS STOLEN.
MANY OF HIS FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS WERE MURRAYED BY
CASTRO AND HIS THUGS.
HE BARELY MADE IT OUT.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS GETTING
BROKEN DOWN BOATS, INNER TUBES
WITH PADDLES TO GET AWAY FROM
CUBA.
THIS GUY IS TELLING US HOW GREAT
CASTRO IS AND HOW GREAT THE USSR
WAS?
>> HE’S GOTTEN AWAY WITH FOR
YES SAYING HE’S A SOCIALIST.
THIS IS MARXISM.
THIS IS BASED ON THE BELIEVE
THAT NO PERSON HAS ANY VALUES AS
AN INDIVIDUAL.
YOUR VALUE IS THAT YOU’RE A
MEMBER OF A CLASS.
SECOND, MARXISM IS BASED ON THE
BELIEF THAT AN EMPLOYER,
EMPLOYEE, A WORKER AND AN OWNER
CAN’T BOTH HELP EACH OTHER AND
BOTH BE BETTER OFF.
THE WORKER GETS GOOD PAY, THE
EMPLOYER MAKES CAPITOL ON HIS
INVESTMENT.
MARCISM ALWAYS LEADS TO
AUTHORITARIANISM AND
DICTATORSHIP.
IN MY HOME STATE OF FLORIDA, WE
HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME TO THIS
COUNTRY FLEEING SOME OF THE VERY
SAME POLICIES THAT WE’RE SEEING
ADVOCATED ON A DEBATE STAGE.
BERNIE SANDERS IS THE LIKELY
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE AND HE’S A
MARXIST.
>> Sean: YEAR 252 DAYS OUTSIDE A
DEFINING MOMENT IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
I’VE NEVER SEEN A MORE RADICAL
GROUP OF DEMOCRATS AND THESE
IDEAS AND NATIONALIZING
EVERYTHING OR YOU CAN TAKE THE
BLOOMBERG HEALTHCARE PLAN, WHICH
IS IF YOU’RE 95, GO HOME.
SEE YOUR FAMILY.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO PAY FOR YOUR
HEALTHCARE.
GO AND DIE.
HE’S ON TAPE SAYING THAT.
HERE’S MY QUESTION.
YOU HAVE THIS RADICAL GROUP OF
DEMOCRATS.
SOMETHING IS HAPPENING WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ESPECIALLY LAST
10, 12 POLLS, AFRICAN AMERICANS,
HISPANIC AMERICANS, THERE’S A
TRANSFORMATION.
DOUBLING, TRIPLING, QUADRUPLING
THE AMOUNTED OF SUPPORT THAT HE
GOT IN 2016.
DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING AND
WHAT DOES IT MEAN IF IT’S REAL?
>> I THINK PART OF IT FRANKLY IS
JUST HOW OFF THE RAILS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BECOME.
LOOK, THEY ALL WILL SAY AND
BERNIE SANDERS IN PARTICULAR
WILL SAY WE STILL BELIEVE IN
PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
THEY LIKE TO COMPEL THEMSELVES
TO NORDIC COUNTRIES.
NORDIC COUNTRIES ARE NOT
SOCIALIST.
I USED TO BUY INTO THAT.
IT’S NOT TRUE.
THEY HAVE FREE ENTERPRISE.
THE AVERAGE CORPORATE TAX RATE
IS AROUND 21%.
THEY DON’T HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE
IN SWEDEN.
THEY HAVE UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
CHOICE NOR EVERYBODY.
SO A BIG WELFARE STATE BUT --
AND HIGH TAXES BUT THEY’RE NOT
SOCIALIST.
THEY’RE TALKING ABOUT
NATIONALIZING HEALTHCARE.
NATIONALIZING ENERGY THROUGH THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE SEC
CONTROLLING THE INTERNET.
THINK ABOUT HOW OUR ECONOMY IS
RUN THROUGH THERE.
YOU’VE NATIONALIZED 60, 70% OF
THE ECONOMY AND WHO KNOWS WHAT
OTHER AREAS.
>> Sean: THE U.S. AS WE KNOW IT
WHICH HAS CREATED A STANDARD OF
LIVING AND ADVANCED THE HUMAN
LIVING CONDITION UNDER
CAPITOLISM WOULD BE -- WE WOULD